[Music]
Battle Damage i'm jake from vsauce3 and
i'm curious what would survive a
playstation 4 or an xbox one through a
series of grueling tests which could
take more battle damage
[Music]
we're pitting the two biggest brands in
gaming head-to-head in this special
first time ever
knockout episode while the specs are
similar we're about to find out which
one of these two consoles is the
toughest battle damage does three tests
drop from a normal height drop them very
high and finally a very scientific no
we're gonna chop the loser in half with
a chainsaw
[Music]
and joining us on set for the first test
Jake and Michael from Vsauce it's okay I
have a ps4 I think it's better system
the Xbox is ugly and huge Xbox has
better games halo no one likes halo it's
like so mm whatever roll action
physically this is almost the exact same
amount of damage
okay well it's alright okay ready okay
here we go three two one
first boot up
look boot up and all know it's doing
something Safe Mode xbox doesn't care
about safety the ps4 is like young guys
let's make sure the kids are safe I'm
already playing games you're in the
urine safety land over there it's
booting up they've both passed alright
let's take it up top and gets the tie I
don't think it's gonna be a tie after
this next test I think they might both
break this is the one I feel the worst
about I know gamers everywhere are
crying roll action
oh there's definitely some loose stuff
in there same piece off this one I'm
confident
come on PlayStation ready and your seems
like it's a little you seem you seem
nervous I'm not as confident as I was
I feel fine up top I feel fine what
thought yours are mine that was mine I
don't even see a light bro is that it
wow that's such a beautiful screen oh
wait I'm plugging in the controller I
think the power buttons broken I'm not
giving up there huh that's cool I'm just
gonna play some game sounds like nothing
it's not making any sound it is dead
even though the PlayStation has better
games a more comfortable controller
I guess structurally the Xbox yes
slightly better so that means the
PlayStation gets the chainsaw treatment
sorry buddy
[Music]
all right Eric you wanna make your point
frickin xbox is better damn
big thanks to michael and jake from
vsauce3 questing this epic doubleheader
episode let us know a console you want
us to battle test next down there in the
comments I can't believe the Xbox one I
can easily believe it I knew it did the
Xbox one the Xbox one Xbox one one I'm
funny
you still lost